The point is that the convergence between a product and engineering company,...
...that's what Sony was, to a brand, that's what Walkman became, to a total experience...
...is what is going to be critical for the future of branding and marketing.
Nike is a company who is doing that today.
Nike was running shoes,...
...then Nike was a brand slogan: "Just Do It."
Today, Nike is an experience.
It's an experience in exercise.
It's an experience in entertainment.
It's an experience in digital lifestyle.
When you plug your iPod; who would have thought that you would plug your iPod?
When Mr. Morita created the Walkman,...
...who would have thought he would be plugging it into his shoe one day?